this is a production of cornell
university
great well good afternoon everyone i'm
excited to
talk to you about my dissertation
research today uh titled
genomics-assisted breeding of malting
barley for new york
state so by the year 2050 it's expected
that there will be 9 billion people
on this world and food production will
be challenged by
increased population climate change and
land degradation
that means well we're going to need more
beer
and that means we need more barley
barley is a diploid grass that's been
the primary ingredient in brewing and
distilling for millennia
there are two primary classifications of
barley the first is by how the grains
are arranged on the spike
and that's two row versus six row the
picture on the right shows two row
barley
and the second is by vernalization
requirement winter barley is planted in
the fall
and spring barley is planted in the
spring i will primarily be talking about
two-row spring malting barley today
in north america most barley production
is in the west in the united states
in montana idaho and north dakota and in
canada
and the prairie provinces of alberta
saskatchewan and manitoba
however new york state has a strong
barley heritage
in the mid-1800s new york was a barley
production powerhouse
with most with most acreage focused in
the western part of the state
along the erie canal this fed large malt
houses and breweries in buffalo
but continued westward agricultural
expansion
as well as a series of tariffs with
canada killed malting barley production
in the late 1800s
and barley has since languished as a
major crop in new york since then
but that's beginning to change in 2012
the new york state legislature passed
the farm brewery bill
this legislation created a new class of
craft brewery new york farm breweries
receive economic incentives and the fun
tagline of being a farm brewery
if they use locally grown grain and hops
in their
beers now the
in 2012 there was no malting barley
production in new york
uh so we had to cornell this task with
increasing malting barley acreage
but so far this uh farm brewery bill has
already led to massive growth in the
number of breweries in new york state
there are now over 400 breweries in new
york which places us in the top five
in terms of a number of breweries per
state
so in 2013 uh mark started trialing
barley varieties from western north
america and europe
to try and find varieties that would
suit local production
as well as craft malting and brewing in
the state
but the typically wet and humid growing
season that
can be rather unpredictable in new york
introduced a lot of challenges in barley
production
and these were agronomic disease and
quality challenges so
because none of the varieties that we
trialled were really a good fit for us
we decided to initiate our own breeding
program
for two row spring malting barley so
that we could service the needs of farm
breweries
within new york state and we named this
breeding project the born
bred and brewed in new york project
now the farm brewery bill has pretty
strict quotas for how much grain
is needed to be a farm brewery and by
2024
that quota for farm breweries is 90 of
their grain bill
so that means that we needed to act
quickly in order to
release a superior malting barley
variety
that met the needs of local growers and
end users
now until recently the only selectable
marker that
plant breeders used was a can of spray
paint and spray paint still has its uses
in the breeding nursery
but the advent of molecular markers has
radically changed how we think about
breeding
and structure our breeding programs the
term marker assisted breeding has been
used for the past
two decades or so to refer to methods
and technologies to implement
molecular markers into the breeding
program
i prefer the term genomics assisted
breeding
because in the 2020s and the 2010s
we now have access to genome-wide
molecular resources
that really expand the range of options
available to breeding programs
but the question is how do we integrate
these resources into a breeding program
to increase our efficiency and accuracy
so in barley we're likely to have some
very high quality genomics resources
these include a high quality reference
genome a recent 20 accession pan genome
and a 50k snip chip that is built upon
previous smaller snip chips for nice
continuity
so my interest is to use these genomics
technologies
to improve quantitative analysis that
supports breeding decision
in our brand new barley breeding program
so i'll be describing a few different
methods of how i've employed
genome-wide association improving
genotype and environment interaction
modeling
and genomic prediction and selection to
aid our efforts
to support craft brewing in new york
so this talk will have three main parts
the first will be genetic mapping of
pre-harvest sprouting and seed dormancy
the second will be modeling
environmental sensitivity of pre-harvest
sprouting
and the third we'll take a look at our
efforts to apply genomic prediction and
selection in a new barley breeding
program
we will start with pre-harvest sprouting
so i've used the term malting several
times to describe the sort of barley
we're working with
barley can also be used for human food
and animal feed
but the highest value is for malting but
what actually is malting
steel grains store energy in the form of
starch
but germinating seedlings needs simpler
sugars in order to grow
yeast also need to eat simpler sugars to
make alcohol during the fermentation
process
so malting takes advantage of the
natural germination process
to prime the conversion of starch to
sugar
so malting has three basic steps first
the grain is soaked or steeped
to initiate germination germination is
then allowed to proceed for three to
four days
and then germination is arrested in the
killing stage where dry heat is applied
and that also helps preserve enzyme
activity and develop color and flavor
so why do we care about enzyme activity
amylases are the enzymes that break down
starch into simpler sugars
and that actual conversion of starch to
sugar does not happen until the first
step of the brewing process
but malting kind of primes the grain in
order to
be able to make alcohol efficiently
there's a protective matrix of protein
and beta-glucan that surrounds the small
starch molecules within the barley grain
and during the germination process this
matrix is broken down
and amylase enzymes are activated this
is called modification and uniform
rapid germination of barley seeds in the
malt house
is needed for efficient complete
modification
malting quality is actually a suite of
10 to 12
quantitatively inherited traits that are
all related to
grain modification and grain chemistry
protein and starch
and as you might expect phenotyping is
slow
expensive and requires a lot of grain
much like other quality traits
seed dormancy is the inability of the
seed to germinate under otherwise
favorable conditions
and seed dormancy is a very important
consideration in malting
because malt houses require germination
to make malt
they require non-dormant grain and in
the context of malting there are
two primary phenotypes that we're
interested in when it comes to seed
dormancy
the first is germination energy this is
simply a measure of seed dormancy
that's measured as the germination
percent over three days
with a higher germination energy
indicating no dormancy
and germination index is a measure of
germination rate
over three days the higher germination
index
implying a higher germination rate
so these two traits are important for
malting and
but in new york for our germplasm and
for malt houses in general
we have a limited understanding of how
germination rate changes over time
we're interested in this because
germination rate has been positively
correlated with some multi-quality
traits
it may be a useful proxy for more cost
efficient and time efficient selection
for molten quality traits
seed derma c duration is also important
one
because mountain houses don't want to
sit on dormant grain because they can't
melt it
and two because of its connection with
pre-harvest sprouting
in varieties with very low seed dormancy
wet harvest conditions can sometimes
induce germination on the spike in the
field
and this can completely ruin barley
quality
considering that wet harvest conditions
are frequent
if not the norm in new york this is a
major concern for barley production in
the state
pre-oversprouting is an expensive
phenotype it's very time sensitive
and labor intensive and and our
phenotyping method requires
hand sampling at a specific maturity
stage
after ripening or drying for three days
and then setting up on styrofoam trays
that we put in a mist chamber in our
greenhouse
these are then misted for three days to
enjo to induce sprouting
and we score them on a zero to nine
scale here i shows only zero to seven
but zero there's no root or shoot
emergence
and seven you can see many green shoots
and many roots which indicates severe
sprouting
pre-ever sprouting is highly heritable
within year which helps breeders
but some varieties have substantial
across your variation
the biggest challenge with pre-harvest
sprouting is that it's often negatively
correlated with malting quality
this is not surprising considering that
high
seed dormancy as generally connected
with pre-harvest sprouting resistance
and high seed dormancy is also
associated with
slow germination and poor malting
quality
so our goal for craft brewing craft
breweries in new york is to try and see
if we can select for pre-harvest
sprouting resistance
and good malting quality because of the
economic importance of these traits
a number of genetic mapping studies have
been conducted in diverse barley
populations for these traits
and two consistently detected qtl on
chromosome 5h
have been detected for both periover
sprouting and c
dormancy the first locus c dormancy 1
or sd1 there has been an alanine amino
transferase cloned at this locus
there's also been an ally t1 associated
with purist sprouting in wheat
and the second locus c dormancy 2
is a map kinase kinase 3 has been cloned
at this locus
and mkk3 has also been associated with
pre-harvest sprouting in wheat
and rice so these two large effects
unlinked genes on chromosome 5-h have
already been cloned
why are we trying to map these at sd2
malting quality and pre-harvest
sprouting qtl are known to co-locate and
are negatively correlated
but it's not known that this correlation
is due to a cluster of tightly linked
genes with separate effects
on malting quality and pre-harbor
sprouting or if it's pliotropic effects
of a single gene
intriguingly in the sd2 region there is
a gibberellin 20 oxidase 1 gene
gibberellin 20 oxidase is involved in
active gibberellin biosynthesis
and gibberellin is a major promoter of
seed germination
j20 ox1 is known to be expressed in
germinating barley seeds
and has also been associated with
pre-harvest sprouting in wheat
and rice if there are variants at ga20x1
and mkk3 and they both have effects on
malting quality
and or pre-harvest sprouting it may be
possible to decouple that tight linkage
through breeding and select for good
pre-harvest sprouting resistance
and good molten quality so our objective
was to identify
and assess temporal interactions of
pre-harvest sprouting
and c dormant cqtl
so before i talk about methods i first
want to acknowledge the substantial
contributions in this section
from my colleague travis rooney so our
approach was to use genome-wide
association for pre-harvest sprouting
and germination traits using three data
sets
the first was a panel of 400 cornell row
spring malting barley breeding lines
and the second was a population composed
of two sources the first was about 80
european land race accessions curated by
the john ennis center from the uk
so abbreviated jic and we added about
20 hullis or naked barley lines from my
colleague carl kunzi's research
for a total of 108 lines in that
subpopulation
the cu and the jic material was grown in
2019 and 2020
and phenotype for prehistoric sprouting
germination energy
and germination index although gic was
only phenotyped for ge
and gi in 2020. both of these
populations were phenotyped with the 50k
snip chip
and the principal component plot on the
right gives an indication of how these
populations are
related this big blue blob on the right
shows that the cu breeding lines are
closely related
while the red jic material and the black
naked material
are substantially more diverse our third
data set
was the result of a collaborative
project with the university of minnesota
this is part of a spring two-row
multi-environment trial
it's abbreviated s2met and these are 200
lines that were composed of breeding
lines from western north american
breeding programs
this is phenotyped for pre-harvest
sprouting only in 2015 and 2016
and has gbs genotypes
seed germination phenotyping is not a
trivial task
it's uh very labor intensive and
requires
sampling of a large a large amount of
spikes
just after physiological maturity and
hand threshing of all those spikes
because mechanical threshing can damage
the seed coat
which will impact sea dormancy and
germination rates
once we hand threshed all of our samples
we froze those samples at negative 20
seats so we could assay at the same
maturity stage
and then we hand counted and plated 30
kernels per sample
and hand counted the number of
germinated kernels
each day for three days to measure ge
and gi
because we are interested in how ge and
gi changed over time
we assayed at multiple after ripening
time points in each year
ranging from about one week after
physiological maturity
to about three months and we increased
our sampling frequency in 2020 to six
time points
so because we knew that we were
interested in three specific
seed dormancy genes we collaborated with
the usda
cereal crops research unit and jason
wallings group
to sanger sequence panels of released
cultivars and breeding lines
winter and spring material for alanine
amino transferase
ga20x1 and mkk3
and based on these sanger sequencing
results to support our
and refine our genomic association
mapping
i developed casp assays for each of
these three genes
so i was able to develop a cast marker
that amplified the causal variants in
the ale at1 which is very useful
when we singer sequence g820 aux 1 we
detected four different alleles of g820
ox1
but no non-synonymous mutations in the
exons
and none of the alleles were obviously
associated with pre-harvest scrolling
variation
nevertheless i developed a casp assay
that amplified a five-prime utr snip
in ga20x1 that differentiated between
the two most common alleles
i then developed two markers to genotype
mkk3
and this is because a paper published by
vetch at all
from montana state and also in
collaboration with jason walling's group
detected three different mkk3 alleles in
modern north american breeding germplasm
vetchat all only associated the n star
mkk3 allele shown in the top row here
with pre-harvest sprouting
susceptibility but i was interested in
the effects
of these second two mkk3 wheels so i
developed one marker
mkk 3e165q to amplify the mutation in
exon 3
that differentiates the n star allele
and i
modified a 50k snip ship marker
that tags the linked variants from exon
7 and exon 8
to differentiate the next two alleles so
going forward it's important to remember
that these two markers
differentiate three alleles of mkk3
so i conducted genome-wide association
analysis using
a multi-locus mixed model in gapit
i added two principal components to
counter population structure
the cu and jic material were analyzed
together
because they were grown in the same
environment and the s2met material was
analyzed separately
and this analysis helped validate a lot
of our cast markers which is exciting
so this plot at the right is a manhattan
plot summary
uh to kind of put all these time points
and all these traits into one hopefully
easy to read plot
and we found that alan ninomiya
transferase the
causal variance was associated with
germination energy
and germination index across time points
so that's shown in this peak here in the
sde-1 region
the mkk3 e165q marker was the only
marker associated with pre-harvest
routing
but was also associated with g e and gi
cross time points
and these are shown in the squares and
are highly significant
however we also detected market trade
associations for the second mkk3 marker
for ge and gi across time points
so this data suggests that each of the
three mkk3 alleles
has distinct effects on germination
energy and germination index
we did not detect any market trade
associations for the g820 rx1 marker for
any trade
at any time point and i should mention
that these results are just for the cu
jic material
but we had similar results in the s2met
so showing that data a little bit
differently i group the
phenotypes for pre-harvest sprouting for
the cujic population
by their large effect c dormancy
haplotype
so the haplotype is defined as the
combination of alleles at
alanine aminotransferase g820 ox1
and mkk3 with n signifying non-dormant
and d is signifying dormant so here we
can see that haplotypes that have the
highly non-dormant mkkk3 and star allele
and red and orange are pre-harvest
sprouting susceptible
and in this cu jic population the other
two mkk3 alleles
are all pretty pre-harvest sprouting
resistant
we also don't see any effects of outlet
80 or g820 ox1
on pre-harvest scrolling
when we look at the s2 met data we do
see
effects on pre-overspouting of each of
the mkk3 alleles
so again in red and orange the highly
non-dormant and star alleles very
pre-harvest crowding susceptible
in blue the weakly non-dormant and
allele
is somewhat pre-harvested sparing
susceptible and there's more dormancy
conferred
by the dormant mkk3d allele and once
again g820x1 has no effect on
pre-harvest sprouting here
so the effects of the mkk3 alleles
become a little bit more clear
when we look at germination index and
germination energy
and how those change over time in the cu
jic material
so on the top we have germination index
and germination energies on the bottom
and each of these these facets show uh
these germination traits
at six days after maturity 48 days after
maturity
and 111 days after maturity
and uh similar to prepare for sprouting
we see that the highly non-dormant and
star allele
has high germination index so it sprouts
quickly
across all time points and has no
primary seed dormancy
and that not surprisingly lasts
throughout the after ripening period
whereas the dormant allele has a much
slower germination rate
at all time points compared to the most
non-dormant allele
and has substantially higher seed
primary seed dormancy
that persists at least a month and a
half after maturity
note though that the effect of the
dormant mkk3 allele
is conditioned by the state of alanine
immunotransferase one dormant alloy at1
combined with the dormant mkk 3d
provides very high c dormancy that
persists the longest of any haplotype
this also is combined with a very slow
germination rate
so these are not good malting lines
because they germinate too slow
and are too dormant mkk3n though has
some favorable haplotypes for malting
and brewing
especially the combination of
non-dormant alanine immunotransferase
and non-dormant uh the weekly non-german
mkk3
these have very low primary seed
dormancy
and a good germination rate uh that
event that quickly approaches the
germination rate of the most non-dormant
and star alleles they also have
pre-harvest sprouting resistance
so these data suggest that the three
mkk-3 alleles
are responsible for effects of pre-over
sprouting
and seed germination traits at sd2 and
not
jibril antonio oxidase one
and i want to highlight this a little
bit more because i think this is one of
the more interesting broader
implications for this work
and how we interpret gr results so
before
i added the casp assays i just had my
50k
marker set and i had about 14 000
markers
it was a good dense set in this region
but because of the highly structured
nature of the cornell breeding material
the marker and closest linkage with the
or the highest linkage with the n-star
allele
happen to be in this ld block that
conveniently surrounded g820 aux-1
and there is a separate ld block that's
surrounded mkk 3.
so i was convinced for several months
actually that we did have variants at
ga20x1
and mkk3 but until we complete our
sanger sequencing of j20x1
and developed cast assays for both of
these markers
and then adding the more diverse
material from the jic
to the gui analysis then i was able to
pick these genetic signals apart a
little bit and realize that
it was actually two alleles are sorry
three alleles
from two markers at mkkk3 and both of
these markers were in different minor
leo frequency which is why we could
detect them in the first place
so for anybody else trying to do genetic
mapping especially if you have a
population that has extended linkages
equilibrium
limited or no recombination between two
loci of interest
and low marker density which is the case
for
many previously published by parental
populations
you might have this illusion of two
separate loci that
could possibly be multiple alleles of a
single
gene so now that we know the primary
genetic effects
of our primary genetic effects on
pre-harvest sprouting
i was interested in trying to answer the
question of why some varieties are so
variable in pre-harvest sprouting across
years while others are very pre-harvest
sprouting stable
so to do that a quick primer on seed
germination physiology
will help us begin seed germination is a
complicated physiological process
conditioned by interactions between many
plant hormones and environmental stimuli
but the two most important hormones are
abscisic acid abbreviated aba
and gibberellic acid abbreviated ga aba
promotes seed dormancy while ga promotes
seed germination
and the balance of those two promotes
whether the seed will germinate
or be dormant given favorable conditions
there are many genes that impact
the biosynthesis and signaling of both
of these hormones
but of interest to us today is that
temperature is known to have an effect
on aba biosynthesis and signaling and
barley
temperature is also known to have an
effect on pre-harvest sprouting and
barley and other cereal grains
with higher temperatures increasing
pre-harvest sprouting susceptibility
and decreasing aba levels
so classically in plant breeding uh the
way that we try to
determine the factors that determine how
a plant looks
so in this case barley pre-harvest
sprouting we partition that
into the impact of genetics
g the environment that that plant grew
up in e
and the interaction of those two factors
genotype by environment interaction
so i decided to take a qtl by e-modeling
approach to try and explain
annual variation in pre-harvest
sprouting i did this because we had
information
on large effect c dormancy qtl so i
could fit those
as their own effect and then model any
residual
quantitative background genetic variants
as g
for environment i divided it into
physical gear location combinations
and decided to model environmental
covariates as well
these are things like temperature and
precipitation that might affect
pre-hybrid sparring susceptibility
and then g by e term is just the
interaction of each of these factors
so i modeled my approach after malice
seti at all for qtl by e-modeling
i fit main effects for physical
environment
qtl and genotype of residual genotype
and then fit interactions between all
these factors
the bolded terms were fit as random
effects and all these models were fit in
asrimor
and i used i was able to do this
analysis because we had
five to six years of historic
pre-harvest sprouting data from our
breeding programs
so i modeled spring and winter
pre-harvest sprouting separately
notice that our spring data set is
larger that's because we've invested
more time and effort in spring barley
breeding to this point
and i used five environmental covariates
the first was maximum temperature
and then minimum temperature average
temperature
temperature range and total
precipitation across the grain fill
period
grain fill being defined as flowering
time to pre-cover sprouting sampling
dates
notice that temperatures are higher for
the spring-grown grains
and encompass a wider range in
temperatures we have similar
precipitation patterns uh the
temperature data
or the weather data was represented in
the last 30 years in ithaca new york
because the spring dataset was larger we
also were able to sample more seed
dormancy haplotypes
and again these hypotypes are defined as
the combination of alleles at
all 80 g820x1 and mkk3 in order
most importantly to note here the spring
data set
had observations for all three mkk3
alleles
for the n-star the n and then the
dormant
while the winter data set just had the
highly non-dormant n-star
and the dormant alleles
so based on part one uh we learned that
pre-oversprouting
is the function of genotype but this
these results
uh strongly suggested that environment
and g by e
have large impacts as well best model
fit was determined by aic
and total precipitation was the best
model fit for the spring model
temperature range was the best fit for
winter
but somewhat more interpretable maximum
temperature
was a good fit for both the plot on the
right shows the percent variance
explained by each of the random model
terms
with red being the residual background
quantitative genetic variants
yellow which is not really detectable on
the winters but is this thin line here
in the springs
this is genotype by environmental
covariate interaction
so genotype by temperature blue
is genotype by physical environment
interaction
green is qtl by physical environment
interaction
and then black as residual error so
for all temperature covariates are all
weather covariates
and spring and winter data sets the
fixed environment
and qtl effects were always significant
but
in the spring we had higher proportions
of genetic
and genotype by environmental covariate
interaction variants
and this is possibly just simply a
function of having more
entries in the spring data set 61 as
opposed to about 25 in the winters
whereas the winters had substantially
higher qtl by physical environment
interaction
and this may have been a result of some
material being
pretty unadapted to cold new york
winters and having severe winter kill
or very bad disease problems in some
years which could impact flowering time
and the grain filteration
so if you look at this a little bit
closer we can see that there is
pre-harvest sprouting temperature
sensitivity that varies within and
between seed dormancy haplotypes
so these plots show environmental
sensitivity
uh for the winter and the spring data
set specifically for
maximum high temperature during grain
fill
and these top two plots on the winters
are the highly non-dormant mkk3 and star
allele
and we can see as we learned in part one
they have a high baseline pre-harvest
sprouting
but that that pre-herb sprouting
increases
as temperature increases we see a
similar pattern
for both of the spring n-star allele
classes
while for the dormant allele we have
high prehiberosphere and resistance
that really stays very stable as
temperature increases
and we see similar results for each of
the dormant mkk3 groups
in the springs and in some cases
pre-harvest spreading risk actually
decreases a bit
as temperature goes up now interestingly
for the springs
the non-dominant mkk3 allele generally
starts as pre-harvest sprouting
resistant
but is very temperature sensitive with
many lines becoming susceptible
as temperature increases four to five
degrees
also note that for the springs
especially there's a large amount of
variation
uh in intercept and i forgot to mention
that the black lines here
are the main qtl by environmental
covariate interactions
so these are the main qtl by temperature
interactions
variation intercept is due to residual
genetic effects
so these are individual effects of
varieties and then any variation in
slope
is unique variation in a variety by
temperature sensitivity so we actually
have some crossover interactions
for the spring material this is an
interest because it suggests that within
haplotype group there is
some quantitative variation remaining
for pre-harvest sprouting resistance
which may be useful for breeding efforts
these results were further supported by
our old friend the s2met data set
and conveniently for me the s2met was
grown in a very cool and wet year
in ithaca in 2015 and a hot drought year
in 2016.
and we can see that the non-dormant
highly non-dermate and star allele in
red
was pre-harvest sprouting susceptible in
both
environmental conditions whereas the
other two mkk3 alleles
were dormant in 2015 and became
non-dormant at different rates
in 2016. so we had more temperature
sensitivity in the blue
and allele and less temperature
sensitivity in the gray
dormant allele i don't have time to get
too much into the weeds with the
physiology of aba temperature
sensitivity
and how mkk3 is interacting with aba
but based on what we do know about the
action of mkk 3
and aba the temperature sensitivity of
mk
k3 is likely related to aba sensitivity
okay so simply uh mkk3n star
has low aba sensitivity uh mkk3n
has modern aba sensitivity and mkk3d
likely is highly aba sensitive
okay so what are the breeding
implications of these first two sections
and just kind of the the take-home notes
here
so importantly at the st2 locus
plyotropic effects from multiple are
polytropic effects of that locus
are strongly suggested to be caused by
multiple
mkk3 alleles not tight linkage with
ga20x1 and mkk3
and there are no other strong candidates
in the st2 region for c dormant's your
pre-herb sprouting
they could still be there but there are
none that seem likely
g820x1 was by far the best candidate
and this should help breeding efforts
because the cast markers for
these two genes should help breeders
select an appropriate sea dormancy level
for their target population of
environments
as well as their target multi-quality
profile
and uh maybe if we have time at the very
end i can show a slide with some
preliminary
multi-quality mapping results and the
s2met with the mkk3 data
but it does seem that there are
plyotropic effects of the
highly non-dormant and star allele on
some but not all multi-quality traits
and those multi-quality traits are more
specifically associated with
a multi-quality profile preferred by
industrial
malting and brewing not craft multi and
brewing
so this is promising because it suggests
that selection for pre-harvest sprouting
resistance
short primary seed dormancy high
germination index
and good craft malting quality does seem
possible for us in new york
and other areas trying to grow good
craft malt
and then importantly for production and
for breeding efforts
uh mkk3 alleles have varying temperature
stability
for breeding this means that breeders
need to continue to test within
mkkk3 allele to see
how stable those alleles are across
years
and these models could also be used as a
predictive tool for growers
to forecast if a particular variety will
sprout
given the weather up to harvest time
so mostly moving away from sea dermatory
sprouting
i want to close by describing some of
our efforts to apply genomic prediction
and selection within our new multi
barley breeding program
so for thousands of years plant breeders
have successfully
selected on a plant's phenotype just how
the plant looks
and that has allowed us to make genetic
gain
and form agriculture as we know it
but the introduction molecular markers
means that we can now
select much more efficiently and much
more accurately
than purely phenotypic selection and
much ink has been spilled within our lab
other labs at cornell and now
research groups globally on the promise
and applications of genomic prediction
and genomic selection
i'll just qualify here that genomic
prediction
is referring to actual prediction
of plant performance based on genotypes
whereas genomic selection
is using genomic predictions within an
actual breeding framework
so in a nutshell uh we are able genomic
prediction
we're able to capture the relationship
between individuals
based on their genotypic data that we
assess with molecular markers
in a genotype matrix and there are
many possible benefits of genomic
prediction
but three of the big ones are potential
to predict
unphenotyped individuals and
unphenotyped locations
which can save a lot of time and money
increase breeding cycle time which may
increase rates of genetic gain and
improve our selection accuracy within
families so the key for genomic
production success
is having a good training population so
this cartoon on the right is a very
simplified version of how genomic
prediction
is structured you have a representative
training population which is just
different breeding lines or different
types of plants
that you genotype with molecular markers
and phenotype
for your traits of interest plug that
data into a statistical model
and that predicts your target test
population of plants
and these test plants are only genotyped
so the key to good genomic prediction
relies in having
high relationship between your training
and your test sets
a good size training population with
density of markers to
capture all the haplotype blocks and
sufficient phenotypic variation for your
trait of interest
so given that we were trying to breed as
quickly as possible
and that uh let's be honest i'm in
mark's lab
and we've done a lot of genomic
prediction work and i probably didn't
have a choice
but i wanted to learn how to do this so
our method to breed uh multiple quickly
was to use genomic prediction and
selection and
we decided to structure our training
population as a connected half
civ population so
very simply this population involves the
crossing of multiple
parents to a common parent so for very
very structured connected population
this gives us a couple of advantage
potential advantages for increasing
prediction accuracy
the first is that we can leverage across
and within family variation
it gives us high statistical power for
genome-wide association analysis
and we're not interested in
understanding the genetic architecture
per se
of the traits but it's more to detect a
large effect loci
that could be added to the prediction
model to further
increase prediction accuracy it also
allows us to
efficiently genotype where we can
genotype the parents at a high plex
and then impute the progeny that our
genotyped at a lower plex
and this population naturally has high
relatedness which is
bound to be good for prediction accuracy
and
allows us to ask some interesting
prediction questions about
combining across and within family
training sets
so again this is the structure that we
actually used aac synergy
is the the most popular variety that we
have now in new york
but it has some disease issues and is
very prehistoric susceptible
so this is our kind of elite malting
background and these are other malting
barley variety parents that we crossed
to synergy so
the training population that i developed
ended up being about 1300 lines
in those seven families and these were
planted in two locations in ithaca
in 2017 and meter long headrows as shown
here
and these were phenotypes for agronomic
traits
quality traits and disease traits and
genotyped with about 6000 gbs markers
and single trait g but models were fit
for each of these traits
i explored a range of prediction
accuracy and cross validation questions
but i want to talk about the actual
genomic selection process
so if you're interested in those those
are publishing crop science early in
2020
okay so over the course of three years i
was able to complete two cycles of
genomic selection
and i actually selected on base
selection
index values that were calculated from
gebv's
calculated from the single trait gbelt
models
so agronomic traits like heading date
and height were lightly weighted
because we weren't sure what our target
range for those traits were yet
and traits like preview river sprouting
and spot watch were heavily weighted
so this diagram on the right has a
little cartoon of the selection scheme
this shows the training population in
each of the seven families
i dropped two of the families from
selection because they were highly
related to synergy and had low
variance for our traits of interest so
based on selection index values i
selected the top two lines from each of
the remaining families
and intermated them in all the possible
half sid matings
so that means that the two sc lines were
not intermitted
to try and stave off severe inbreeding
but were insurmated with all their half
sibs so these selections are made using
genomic prediction and also just
phenotypic selection
so that resulted in 211 phenotypically
selected lines
and about 370 cycle 1 genomic lines
cycle 1 genomic lines were genotyped at
the f2 stage
with a subset of gbs markers that were
converted to an lgc snip assay
and the predicted top 15 lines were then
intermeded
to create cycle 2g
so to evaluate gain from selection i
needed to evaluate these populations in
the same field
population 17 2017 was far too large to
plant again
so i randomly sampled 15 lines from each
family
to perform a proxy training population
that i called c0
100 c1 phenotypic lines were randomly
selected
the top 92 c1 g lines were selected
and then all 100 c2g lines were selected
so these cycles were simultaneously
grown in two locations each in 2019 and
2020.
there are phenotype for heading date
height pre-harvest sprouting
and then spot blotch phenotypes were
taken in the greenhouse
for seedling assays and all the
correlated germination traits that i
talked about in section
one that was taken from this popu this
experiment in both years and these were
phenotype or genotyped with about 21 000
markers
to look at inbreeding
so i compared realized versus expected
genetic gain and for each of the traits
and for the overall selection index
an expected gain for component traits
within a selection index was calculated
with this equation where
g and p are the respective genotypic and
phenotypic covariance matrices
w is a vector of trait weights
and i is a selection intensity so
this figure here shows realize versus
expected gain
across cycles pink is the realized
genetic gain
and blue is expected genetic gain and
the genomic selection cycles are shown
in solid lines
while the dashed lines represent
phenotypic selection
so we did have gain for pre-harvest
sprouting and overall selection index
with small gains for heading date and
height but even though spotlight
was heavily weighted there was not gain
for spot watch
and my best guess is why that happened
is that phenotyping for stopwatch in the
training population
was rather difficult due to confounding
of early leaf senescence with disease
symptoms
and expected and observed gain were
pretty similar from cycle 0 to cycle 1
for each trait
but were substantially different for
between cycle 1 and cycle 2.
and this may have been due to difficulty
estimating the genotypic and phenotypic
covariance matrices
from cycle one to estimate cycle two
one of the primary concerns about
aggressive use of genomic selection
is that it can rapidly deplete genetic
variants and
increase inbreeding compared to
phenotypic selection
so we observed a reduction in genetic
variants for pre-harvest sprouting
with genomic selection cycles in blue
compared to the phenotypic selection and
yellow
but that's also because we actually had
gain from selection to pre-harvest
sprouting
for genomic selection compared to
pre-harvest or
phenotypic selection but for the lightly
weighted traits heavy date and height we
really did not deplete our genetic
variants very much
and this gives me some hope that we also
didn't deplete
genetic variants for yields which we
have not been able to measure on these
traits yet
we did see that average genomic
relationship and monomorphic market
percentage
increased with two cycles of genomic
selection compared to one cycle of
phenotypic selection
but the inbreeding could have been much
worse i mentioned earlier that i
purposely avoided full submating
and if i were based on simulation if i
were to have only selected the top
10 selection and predicted selection
index value lines
within each cycle and intermediated
those
inbreeding after two cycles of gs would
have been at least
0.55 instead of 0.41
so again taking a step back a little bit
and looking
what is this project tell us about
applied genomic selection
i think the biggest question for us that
is still
under evaluation because we don't have
all the data yet
is was gs worth the cost in our breeding
program as i mentioned uh
because i had to graduate we grew the
game from selection trial and headrows
and we didn't have enough c
to grow them in yield trial plots
so we don't know what the yield is on
these yet and we don't yet know what the
malting quality is
on these lines although jason wong's
group at ccru
is currently working on us with getting
those phenotypes
so i think you know if we did not
deplete variation for malting quality
and yield i think this is a
was a successful approach although the
lack of gain
for spot watch was discouraging and
given what we now know about the genetic
architecture pre-harvest sprouting in
our
program marker assisted selection
if we were only selecting our
pre-harvest sprouting may be
more useful but the selection index
does seem to potentially be useful for
gain for component and overall selection
index component traits and selection
index
so i mentioned some uh advantages of
using a connected half-civ training
population earlier
but i want to bring up a couple
potential consequences to think about as
well
the first is founder diversity a couple
of the parents that we selected were
very closely related to each other
and that limited our prediction accuracy
within those families and limited
genetic variation
so if i were to do this again i would
probably selected
more founders and had smaller family
sizes
and that would have helped us manage
inbreeding a little bit although within
this connected half civ
population you are inherently going to
have inbreeding because everything
shares a single parent initially
but the importance of these first two
factors does depend on your short versus
long-term breeding goals
we knew that we had a very short-term
focus from the get-go
we were really focused on five and then
maybe 10 years out
but using this so for a very intense
aggressive
selection program that needs to get a
variety out quickly
this might be a useful approach but for
longer term sustained gain
would probably need some more careful
evaluation
and lastly uh is the
statistical power afforded by the
connected half sid population
we sure we can do gua but is that worth
it because most of the time breeders are
not really interested in the underlying
genetic architecture per se
but i think for something like disease
resistance this could actually be quite
useful
because knowing if you have a limited
number of large effects disease
resistance low sight in your breeding
program
would be useful to manage long-term
evolution of disease resistance
so while this genomic selection program
was progressing i was also managing our
two
spring malting barley breeding program
and as mark mentioned in the
introduction
we've rapidly progressed this using a
combination of genomic prediction
and winter nursery to go from first
crosses in 2016
to foundation seed non-farm trials in
2021
and mark also let the cat out of the bag
a little bit but
this led to the release of the first
ever two row spring malting barley
variety from cornell
which was christened excelsior gold by
the new york malting barley community
excelsior is the state mod of new york
and gold is the color of barley and the
color of beer
so excelsior gold has yield comparable
to
our agronomic checks with good fourier
disease resistance
and fusion head blight resistance which
is a big problem in new york
and importantly it has good pre-harvest
sprouting resistance it actually has the
mkk3d allele if you're curious
and a short post harvest sea dormancy
period with a good germination rate
and acceptable malting quality
so with that i have some
acknowledgements uh i first really want
to thank new york agriculture and
markets
they have been the primary sponsor of my
phd research
so very grateful for their support of
our research and malting barley in new
york
a lot of the seed dormancy work was
sponsored by the american malting braley
association and the brewers association
and a grant from the cornell center for
technology licensing
helped us push excelsior gold out the
door
i also really want to highlight the
contributions of the new york malting
barley community at large
it's been a really fun group of people
to work with and to learn from
in my time here they're very passionate
about their craft and their trade
and they've been really interested in
what we're doing at cornell and very
supportive of our research
and i especially want to thank andrea
stanley ted hawley and dennis nessel
for their contributions and
collaborations to our research
so in terms of specific people i first
want to thank my committee
mark sorels gary bergstrom and jessica
rudkoski
they've been great to work with and have
really supported me well this entire
time a special shout out to jessica for
sticking with me through several career
moves
so thank you very much jessica your
input is always always appreciated
the yannick sorrels group specifically
i want to start with david venture amy
fox and james tsunaka our technicians
we would not be able to do anything in
sorel's lab if not for them
and they make coming to work a lot of
fun and a great joy especially during
summer field season
so i'll miss the three of you quite a
bit uh
i've really been blessed to have
fantastic lab mates the entire time i've
been here
and i want to first thank former
colleagues nick san antonio and lynn
vinstra
for being patient with me and answering
many many questions my first few years
so i've tried to return the favor once i
was a senior grad student but big thank
you to both of you
chantal martinez is a former postdoc who
contributed a lot
to see dormancy work and
carl kavansi and travis cerny especially
have collaborated a lot on all the
barley breeding and the seed dormancy
work
at usda's cereal crops research unit
jason walling
and technician leslie zalapa have been
excellent collaborators
jen starr and gary bergstrom's lab
helped me a lot with all the spot blotch
inoculum prep and phenotyping
at heartwood college in oneonta new york
the craft food and beverage center
aaron macleod has been just a tremendous
supporter of the farm brewery
activity and malting in barley new york
in general
and he's taught me an incredible amount
about malting and malting quality
and i hope that we've been able to teach
you a little bit about barley breeding
aaron
so thanks for all of your help and
christopher redout at the john dennis
center
uh has been was the collaborator on the
gic material
and a few miscellaneous thanks uh chris
hernandez has been my housemate for the
last
six years the entire time i've been here
and i've learned more from him about
plant breeding than
anybody else or any seminar so thank you
to chris and thanks for putting up with
me for so long
to synapsis the plant breeding graduate
students
you've been a great source of friendship
and ideas and i really look forward to
networking and collaborating with you
for my whole career
the cornell catholic community has been
a great source of fellowship and support
in my time here
and then lastly but very importantly my
family has always
very much supported my education through
this entire process
so thank you very very much for your
love and support
and lastly i just want to say that i've
been really really
thankful to have this opportunity to
study plant breeding and cornell
it was my dream grad school and it's
been a great place to
conduct my dissertation research but
it's given me the opportunity to explore
around the world around the country and
within new york
so my only advice to current grad
students is get out of the gun because
there's a lot of cool stuff
in new york and it's worth exploring
and i would be happy to hear any
questions and comments
so thanks so much for your time thank
you very much dan
we're running a little bit long but if
uh people could take a few more minutes
to
um uh ask some questions
um dan would be glad to see if he can
answer those for you
okay so i see one question from the
mirror lab you generate a lot of data
how do you deal with the data management
challenge
that's a great question and i'll admit
that we did not do a great job of
managing data beforehand
i think that's something as a lab we
personally to work on but
my colleague travis journey pushed me
into using github so we've been using
github to manage and share our data and
code a little bit better so
we're working on that but that's
definitely still an active area
i will be uploading a lot of this data
to the t3 breed base
but that hasn't happened yet
well that's probably something i could
do better as an advisor as well
it's a big job any other questions from
anybody
yeah i have a question yeah go ahead
yeah uh so have you looked in the
candidate genes they involved in
aba or ga biosynthesis
and or signaling and looking to their
possible impact
on c dominancy in body
yeah that's a good question so there has
been a lot of work done in barley
looking
at things like aba hydroxylase and
the nced genes which are also involved
in aba metabolism
i did not look at expression of endless
genes specifically
but i think to get a really good but i
have a feeling that some of those genes
might be underlying some of that
background genetic variation for
temperature sensitivity
and because those genes are helping to
determine how much obscenic acid is in
the grain at any given time
so i didn't look into that specifically
but i think that's definitely an
opportunity for future research
okay thank you
we have another question from
travis travis you want to
ask your question verbally
i i can um so you mentioned the
multi-quality interactions that
um with mkkk3 alleles what have you
found and what are the implications for
the different types of uh brewing
yeah so i very briefly mentioned this
but our
early mulching quality mapping results
in the s2met population suggests that
uh the highly non-german n-star allele
is associated with
some grain modification traits like
soluble over total protein
work protein
and then freemium nitrogen
those are really important traits more
so
for industrial brewing by industrial
brewing i mean like anhyzer bush
miller coors so budweiser miller lite uh
anything like things like yingling um
whereas the craft mulching profile is a
little bit different
and we're thinking that uh
prayer of spreading resistance with the
other two mkk3 alleles
might not be compromising walton quality
and we also found multi-quality
qtl at non-sd2 loci
which is very promising for selecting
for pre-harvest grounding resistance and
good malting
okay well um i don't see any other
questions in the chat box
um i don't see anybody's hand up so
let's uh thank dan for an outstanding
exit seminar
and he'll be around for i think what a
couple more weeks right down
yep uh definitely through may and then
here and there in june
okay thanks very much and thank you
for attending dan's seminar
all right thanks everybody bye-bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu